[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered I'm Peter LaValle
as the election cycle rages on the media
highlights or even invents what they
deem to be important even radical what
they don't tell you is how the political
center is collapsing and why today's
campaign is what voters think about the
status quo
[Music]
crosstalking the liberal collapse I'm
joined by my guest lead on Jones in
Atlanta she's an attorney and former
state director for Bernie Sanders in
2016 in Washington we have Christopher
Baron he is a conservative strategist as
well as president of right turn
strategies and in Strasbourg we cross to
John Lachlan he's a political scientist
and historian as well as lecture in
European history at the University
Institute of st. Pius the tenth in Paris
all right the cross luck rules an effect
that means you can jump in anytime you
want and I always appreciate it let me
go to John and Strasbourg we kind of
give us a little panoramic view right
here I was thinking a couple of days ago
looking at the surge or apparent surge
or invented surge a Peabody jej and I
kept thinking wow America now has its
own version of Emmanuel macron okay I
post your child for power for the status
quo and almost no one likes them but you
can't do anything about it okay that's
exactly what we're facing here and as I
also said in my introduction
you know we're told so much about what
this candidate stands for with that
candidate stands for but nobody really
wants to look at what the voters really
want and they want a continuation of
2016 of confronting the elites okay but
you won't learn that on CNN or MSNBC go
ahead John well I think the comparison
with McCoy is a very good one because
Mack Hall in in France shows that in
spite of all the rhetoric that we had in
2016 about the brexit and the rise of
Trump and so on it shows how strong I
won't call it the political center
because I don't think that's quite the
right word I would say the political
cartel has strong ethical cartel remains
and how determined the political cartel
is to hang on to power in fact I would
almost say that the rhetoric of a sort
of populist breakthrough which some
populist politicians used on both sides
of the Atlantic is almost feeding in to
the horror stories that the cartel tells
in order to keep itself in power it
tells people oh my god you know we're
the only safe pair of hands
right if you
if you elect these terrible populace
like drum walk or vote for brexit or
whatever then the entire system will
come crashing down so I would almost say
that this idea of a sudden breakdown of
the center is itself a part of the
political cartels own mechanism for
staying in power okay I really like the
term that got cartel here Ladon
apparently the cartel doesn't know how
to flip a coin okay because I think our
viewers saw this coin flipping in Iowa
what in the world was that about and it
just backs up exactly what John was
saying they're gonna do anything
anything they stay in power
I mean hypocrisy out the window I mean
that's not even embarrassed by this now
okay and I speak that I say this as a
conservative because I think what's
happening to Bernie is shameful and the
powers that be are backing it up they're
calling someone a front-runner we're
based on no evidence no facts whatsoever
and it's just virtues signaling and you
know what all those people that canvass
through that ridiculous system they have
their hours and hours and hours taking
time off from work and then what you do
is you turn around and spit in their
face sorry for being so blunt but that's
exactly what it is go ahead look under
you that may have been and it's obvious
listen I was an embarrassing mess for
Democrats however I will say one thing
that Bernie Sanders has is maybe this
cartel of people right he has a campaign
that was already built unlike any other
candidate in the race so I'm not gonna
say that the party is trying to rig it
against them again because even if that
is the expectation his people know how
to get around it because they are a
self-organized army despite that this is
a primary and that's what primaries are
about the Democrats are lucky that we
have a wide variety from the left to the
right moderate centrist candidates that
each of us can go out and choose as long
as we actually participate in this
process and not be discouraged by what
happened in Iowa however Iowa was an
eye-opener there's time for us to make
some changes and that's the focus that I
think the Democrats should be on okay go
Chris but it's not an eye opener it's
setting a trend in a precedent okay
don't trust the vote don't trust the
voters trust us the people that are
reporting it okay I mean I think it
patently obvious said Putin Buddha judge
is an invention that this he's been
created to take this role here and you
know with Joe you know flailing and you
know you you have other candidates that
are not reaching the mark a clover char
is nice but you know this it's all a
marketing strategy but it's not the
candidates it's not the parties doing
the marketing it's the media framing the
narrative and I find it so insulting to
the Democratic person and that's what
they did to Trump okay they tried to do
the party okay well okay Christopher
jump it's between what is the difference
between CNN MSNBC and the DNC just think
about that Chris Christopher jump in oh
it's a huge difference I need everyone
in the program first and then we can
jump in it's Christopher's turn go ahead
Christopher you've got John Kerry being
caught on the on a phone in Iowa talking
about how he's thinking about jumping
into the race because he wants to stop
Bernie Sanders look at the end of the
day I think Sanders is actually going to
win this nomination but he's gonna have
to fight like hell for it because the
Democratic establishment and their
friends in the corporate media are gonna
do everything they can to stop him in
the same way that they tried to stop
Donald Trump in 2016 you know what
happened in 2016 is Trump let all the
animals in the party out of their cages
in the Republican Party and if Bernie is
gonna succeed he has to do the same
thing he's gonna have to fight for it
tooth and nail because they will do
everything from inventing characters
like Buddha judge to Bloomberg and his
billions to the onslaught of negative
opposition research which is coming it
is coming it the dump is coming soon for
Bernie Sanders he is going to have to
fight tooth and nail the same way that
Trump did in 2016 and frankly I think
it's good for democracy to have a real
you know a real debate about the future
to have two people standing on stage who
offer very different views for the
future and who actually believe what
they're saying I think it's good for
democracy and good for our country I
think that's a very good point Chris or
not and I take it on board but I think
you can flip the coin I think the
this is a deal it D legitimizing the
democratic process I mean Iowa's a
perfect example of that I don't believe
this story about this app and all this
this is a bit too convenient and Budaj
edges campaign connection to the people
that were involved with that app I mean
that's kind of fishy as well okay John
to me it is it's really holding the
democratic process in contempt because
if they don't get the outcome they want
then they're gonna say it's not
legitimate go ahead well that's
obviously what they did with Trump is
everyone knows first on Russia and then
on Ukraine we'll have to see whether
Bernie Sanders wins the nomination we
have to see if he wins in in New
Hampshire for that matter I'm surprised
that Christopher is is optimistic for
him maybe he's right
but if he is right then America will be
the other states will be breaking the
mold because in Europe but there's
absolutely not what's happening at all
again in spite of all the talk about
populism and the end of consensus and so
on the European picture is very
different the European situation is one
in which the left the old left the sort
of left of Bernie Sanders embodies has
completely collapsed the British Labour
Party has been totally decimated in the
latest general election the Socialist
Party in France barely exists anymore it
had to sell its headquarters in order to
survive financially the Social
Democratic Party in Germany is extremely
weak and although there's some
right-wing populist parties in Europe
had some success the league in Italy the
freedom party in Austria basically they
have also been chased out of office yeah
by the cartel so right now in on this
side of the Atlantic
I'm afraid the cartel is doing extremely
well and certainly as far as for example
France is concerned a Macomb in spite of
his unpopularity has a perfectly good
chance of winning at the time of the
next presidential election in 2022
that's right
you know the ton you know one of the
things I really like about Bernie
Sanders is he talks about real people he
doesn't talk about these newfangled ID
this virtue signaling and all of this I
don't underst I don't get it okay I'm a
political junkie I don't understand most
of the white
particularly on the left okay but I mean
when Bernie talks he talks about real
people and real problems and you know
what he's been doing it for a long time
all right
not you know you know not someone that
was 47 years old and decided to become a
Democrat you know after you know
slogging for financial institutions for
years some time out Elizabeth Warren
here I mean but I think the Democratic
Party is really detached from that the
DNC and the media they like these other
you know extraneous things that day you
know maybe there are people that some
people that are interested in it but
most people that say you know you know
where's the beef you know how am I gonna
make my life better for me that's really
the bread and butter of politics and
Bernie is a chef at it he's great at it
okay very much like Donald Trump you
know though they're obviously
differences go ahead look done well you
know so I would say overall the
Democratic Party is much more in line
with the the people on the ground
actually needed one however I agree with
you Bernie Sanders has been consistent
and talking about the people who are
that bottom percentage of Americans who
simply just need a hand up you talked
about D legitimizing the process you
know Iowa wasn't great but we know from
2016 there's another thing that DD
legitimizes the American process and
that's the electoral college just like
Iowa it is antiquated it is old and we
know that because Trump won although
losing the popular vote and so these
things so we talked about the Democratic
Party but I think the American political
system as a whole
probably needs an overhaul and what we
will see is that it's not a centrist
moving left moving right is that most of
the people care about their everyday
needs making sure they can feed their
family good education for their children
okay with you on that part the electoral
college no way winning I have the
solution Christopher right before we go
to the break why don't we go back to
paper and pencil ballots okay I'm sorry
it seems to work for a whole long time
okay I don't know what's wrong with that
okay
recycled paper we don't have to cut down
trees 40 seconds Christopher before we
go to the break look I think what people
I think what people want in this country
is they they are tired of the the
politics of the elites that didn't work
for average working-class America
that's the appeal of Donald Trump on the
right that's the appeal of Bernie
Sanders on the left and that's why I
said I think it's great for democracy to
actually have an open and honest
discussion about the future instead of
the cartel of the center that's only
interested in the moneyed interest that
it represents that's the system that's
broken and that's the system that both
Donald Trump and Bernie Sanders are an
absolute revolt - okay I'm gonna jump in
here after a short break we'll continue
our discussion on the liberal collapse
stay with our team welcome back to
crosstalk where all things are
considered I'm Peter LaBelle to remind
you were discussing the liberal collapse
[Music]
okay let's go back to John and
Strasbourg I have my own pet theory
about all of this if there isn't a
candidate a Democratic candidate that
comes into vibrant force after Super
Tuesday we're gonna have some kind of
brokered convention here a nice assume
and I'm really interested in with Ladon
will have to say about this but first
the John is that I think the cartel and
I'm gonna start using that terminal
always cite you for it
I think the cartel would prefer to have
Trump have the Democrats lose and have
Trump re-elected because we've seen over
the last three years or so that they've
been able to really come crimp him on
his foreign policy very tightly okay
he's he has no foreign policy real
success in my opinion and you still have
too many of these deep state creatures
even though the finally the VIN VIN min
twins are out of the White House finally
but it's gonna be it's slow-going okay
because it's so bipartisan so what do
you think of that proposition that the
the cartel would prefer to see the
Democrats lose than Bernie Winne go
ahead yeah I understand what you're
driving at I suppose I haven't really
ever thought that Bernie Sanders could
win the presidency so in other words I
think that it's they'll be bowing to be
inevitable trump has kept us guessing
hasn't he beat her ever since he was
elected we have many of us may have
placed hopes in EM particularly on
foreign policy issues and we've been
cruelly disappointed but he carries on
talking the talk even if he's not
walking the walk I suppose that I'm
afraid I'm probably guilty of letting my
hopes carry away carry the day over my
analysis when I say that you know one
hopes or one things that perhaps this
endless deep state conspiracy against
him will come to an end in a second it
wins a second term and that after all
after the impeachment vote on on Tuesday
the there was a bit of a purge wasn't
there as you mentioned the VIN twins
were out the ambassador to the EU was
out Graham Sunderland and so on
if Trump manages to win a second term
maybe he will feel strong enough to
to carry the purge further or at least
to implement the fraud policy that he's
been talking about and he was elected on
but I agree it's a tough one because the
Afeni if the last four years have taught
us anything it is indeed the power by
the way I've said this before on
crosstalk it's not the deep state it's
the state it's the State Department the
Congress the Pentagon it's the whole
apparatus of the state not just the
covert operatives in the in the CIA and
the other intelligence services it's the
whole of the state and that's what makes
the whole challenge of dissident
politicians populist politician so
difficult because even if you're the
president of the United States with the
separation of powers and all the rest of
it and with the general institutional
inertia it is incredibly difficult to
turn things around and you certainly
can't do it in in four years
yeah parent to like mrs. Thatcher in
Britain was in power for more than
eleven years and even how successes
although considerable were no doubt less
considerable than she would have hoped
for so there is a terrible you know
amount of as I say institutional inertia
even for politicians who are radical and
who are determined to be radical yeah
apparently John and John Brennan still
has his security clearance believable
unbelievable Don let me go get me and
give my pet theory to you I mean would
would would you do you think that if
Bernie were to get the nomination which
I think if you if the popular will even
with our antiquated primaries if the
popular will is answered it would be
Bernie but would the DNC prefer to see
him lose and then win against Donald
Trump in November
go ahead Lydon no no I think it is
pretty clear across the board that the
goal is to get Trump out of office by
any means necessary that includes Bernie
Sanders winning so I don't think that
they're going to undermine the process
to that and what I would love to see and
I think what will set the Democrats
apart is that just like changing I are
we need to change some of other
processes you know what I want to know
now for every single person that is in
this primary race who would you pick for
vice president today not active at the
convention right now whether they will
be able
to be your VP or not because that is the
kind of thing okay I'll tell you what I
think from the center left or right I
think I'll tell you what I'll answer
your question killing is a really good
one I think there's only one that can be
president that's Bernie Sanders though I
think he'll be denied it by the DNC and
the media but all the other ones are all
running for vice president okay will
seem it looks like poppy Budaj edge is
getting the not getting the nod somehow
okay that's what it looks like to me it
looks very engineered somebody's got a
white board and they're taking the boxes
okay and it's all against your guy okay
it's against Bernie again let me go to
Christopher here Christopher Bernie
Sanders calls himself a socialist a
Democratic Socialist I do I don't really
know what that means but a lot of people
if you look at public opinion polls I
know what it is I used to be a
university professor okay but I'm
looking at how it's being spun in the
media okay
believe me I've read my share of Marx
angles Lenin Gramsci John smiling at me
we've read all that stuff okay but
Christopher why is think what is the
appeal of socialism as it's it's coined
in American parlance because a public
opinion poll after another shows a lot
of people are quite interested in what
it may have a American accent to it okay
go ahead Christopher I mean I think it's
the it's the the not it's the what we
don't have now I don't think the
majority of Americans are are going to
vote for socialist policies or actually
support socialist policies I think that
they're so absolutely upset with the
establishment yeah that they feel that
our institutions are no longer
responsive to us that they're willing to
accept something anything that's
different and look by the way in 2016
back to your point before Peter in 2016
there were lots of Republicans who
thought fine nominate Trump let him lose
in 40 states and then we can swoop back
in and say see we told you this was
gonna be a disaster
unfortunately for them that's not what
happened I think there are plenty I
think there are plenty of establishment
Democrats who if Bernie wrestles the
nomination from him which I expect are
going to say there'll be the jeb Bush's
of the world Hillary Clinton will say I
used to endorse I'm gonna have our own
Evan McMullen that I'm gonna vote for
and because they expect Bernie to lose
they're so unbelievably out of touch
with where the American people are it is
so bad in 2016
okay done jump in look I look I want
Bernie Sanders to be the nominee little
Adan that's the point of the program
jump in please do I mean the reality is
and I love it I mean I think it's very
creative on the conservative side take
the Russian talking points from last
year from 2016 what was put out on
Twitter was put out on social media and
say we know this makes them angry this
is how we split their party hey
Hillary's Hillary Hillary was your
nominee from four years ago and she's
out there trash-talking your candidate
you shouldn't be upset with me nobody's
out there how many now yet nobody likes
Bernie yeah okay sit down take several
y'all agree
he'll age they go in the forest and say
in the forest okay let me go let me go
let me go to John here John it's good to
reflect upon something that Christopher
just said here I mean you people know
what they don't want now okay and they
don't like the status quo that's the
whole point here and I agree with them
about how people are receptive to
socialism which as three Americans on
the program that word was for Bowdoin
for a very very long time in American
political discourse okay and but I think
that Christopher is absolutely right is
that the status quo isn't working
there's a perception that's not working
for the average person I mean you can
look at all these macroeconomic numbers
which is nice and fine but it doesn't
necessarily you could say yeah the
economy is doing great but you could
also say it's not doing great for me
though okay and I think that's is what I
think the GOP often misses on this is
well okay particularly someone like Sean
Hannity that goes you know every night
it's the litany the same thing over and
over and over again go ahead John people
know what they don't want go ahead John
yeah but the effect is pizza the
the sociological phenomenon that you are
describing which is the disenchantment
of a large section of the electorate you
didn't say it but I think you probably
mean the blue-collar electric ID we used
a working class that disenchantment does
not on track record in either the United
States or Europe translate into votes
for the left it translates into votes
for the right or parties that are called
right-wing populist right-wing it's
those parties and Trump is obviously the
prime example of this the British
Conservative Party is another one it's
those parties that are picking up the
disaffected working-class or blue color
Khanna vote for why you're forgetting in
that there's a huge factor so Democrats
a lot of the left-leaning folks in
America are in the southeast and what do
we see in Tennessee in Georgia and
Mississippi they are closing voting
precincts they are making it more and
more difficult for people to register to
vote
they're purging voters so that number
does come out for Democrats the problem
is there are still conservatives in
charge in the states that can suppress
200,000 250,000 votes at a time making
it difficult for those people who are
energetic and Oh 8 for Obama and oh 12
they're making it a little bit harder
for them to participate in every single
vote count so I think you may be wrong
in that I think it may energize the
rights voters but it also is showing the
suppression of the voters on the web it
might belittle it done but if they
continue to screw but if they continue
to screw around with Bernie I would say
a lot of Bernie supporters simply won't
vote you cheated twice what's the point
the system's broken the system's rigged
and a lot of other people gonna feel the
same way what's the point what's the
point if we if we see another Iowa OK or
something similar to it okay Christopher
I'm gonna give you a last minute on the
program go ahead I'm gonna say
Republicans spent 30 years trying to
find the infamous Reagan Democrats to
their electoral defeat time and time
again and I think Democrats are going to
be on this mysterious hunt for the the
disaffected blue-collar working-class
votes that they have that have
spurned their party and I don't think
there's any way that they're getting
those people back that's not going to be
the future for the Democratic Party
they're not winning back the Trump
voters from Pennsylvania and Michigan
and Wisconsin they're never coming home
again
it took Republicans a long time to
figure out that Reagan Democrats were
actually just Democrats it's gonna take
the Democratic Party a long time to
figure out that the Trump working class
are just Republicans oh and also the
focus on workers which what I'm really
glad that John brought up working people
though it's tough on defined over time
because of technology but families
creating families keeping families
together the opioid crisis real problems
that affect real people okay
and you know and I'll get in trouble for
saying this not just transgender toilets
okay maybe that's there but it's not the
hi and and and I think this this is what
Trump and Bernie Sanders are doing and I
hope to see them face it off in November
us all the time we have many thanks to
my guess an Atlanta Washington and in
Strasbourg and thanks to our viewers for
watching us here at RT see you next time
and remember cross stuck rules
[Music]
you